first I have a little bit of a broader
question for you to start I'm curious
what is something about your definition
of a final girl that stayed the same
from the first movie to now and what is
something about that definition that's
evolved over the years well I think the
ultimate message of the final girl is
that you don't give up I think that's
really
it's the Peter Gabriel song uh sort of
redo into uh one
three word sentence don't give up I I
think Lori strot epitomized not giving
up
this unwitting unexpecting victim of
this horrific violence you know all of
her hopes and dreams dashed her
innocence taken
um life Interrupted by this monster but
no matter what even in 2016 we meet a
woman who hasn't given up definitely an
appropriate description right there so
one thing I was reading in the Press
notes I think David had said this was
that you're already you're always ready
on set with ideas and curveballs so is
there any particular curveball you threw
while you were filming this movie that
now we can see in the finished version
of it um when we were rehearsing the
fight sequence
um which are you know choreographed
pieces of art I mean it's many shots
many angles all sorts of things there's
a there was a moment where I still felt
it felt like a movie fight I was still
fighting the movie fight it's just the
nature my nature sure I'm I'm not a
trained actor I'm an instinctual person
as a performer and uh there's a moment
where Michael grabs Lori's hair and
pushes her face through a glass cabinet
and I said I wanted to be on camera I
want it to be me I want it to be real
that feels important to me that that you
don't see that in the movies very often
when it's the real person unless it's
Tom Cruise apparently who apparently
does everything
um and I admire him so much for it but
that's just one that popped in my mind
that's a that's a rock solid one that is
a wicked fight sequence too it's very
very visceral which is very appropriate
for the end of this franchise speaking
or this Trilogy at least I don't want to
make that assumption because evil
changes shape and it can keep on coming
actually I'll go there next then given
the fact that they do have that line at
the end of the movie that even though
Michael Myers is dead evil can take on a
new shape do you think that there is any
happily ever after for Lori or is there
always going to be that risk that a new
shape can form and manifest evil around
her so is this the spoiler alert oh yeah
this whole video will be labeled with a
spoiler warning okay well I worry
because you know people uh we have
protected I've been around the world and
I have I have I have stayed as far away
from answering anything because
um we work too hard to create
the
inevitable collision between Michael and
Lori it is the entire franchise is built
on that Collision of Good and Evil and
um
you know there were many iterations and
many ideas
of transference between Michael and Lori
there was even a conversation and
that
if she kills she's a killer
and what and then does she have to
isolate for the rest of her life because
she you know
um it there are big big questions
um that we talked about we we there
there were a lot of those conversations
um
I
my contribution and I can't believe I'm
saying this on a camera
to a journalist but I really respect
collider and I know what you guys do
so Universal don't hurt her
okay do not hurt her
um
my contribution to Halloween is that the
last scene takes place on the front
porch of her house
um it's it originally took place in
inside her house in the doorway
and I said to David
I I actually said to David and I had
started to cry when we were talking
about it
I said
Halloween began in Haddonfield on a
on this beautiful fall day with leaves
you know wind blowing leaves and kids
riding bikes and I said
it's not a happy ending movie
there's no celebration
of anything it's sad
but there's a drop of hope that maybe
Maybe
Lori Strode will have a minute
in her life that's
at peace and I said I I really think
Dave we need to move this to the front
porch and I think you need to show kids
on bikes like you have to see
that innocence prevails that peace
prevails
and
that there's a chance for Lori Strode
um broken and hurt and
damaged but
that it's going to be okay
for a minute and that's my contribution
to Halloween really is that it's
on the front porch of her house
on a street
in Haddonfield Illinois
on November 1st
at 8 30 in the morning you feel what you
described it's like I know that endings
can be interpreted different ways and
that's kind of the exciting thing about
film and receiving story that sense of
hope is very very visceral on that porch
at the end of this and it has to be
because if not
what's the point
yeah that's what keeps me coming back
for more with this franchise and other
ones is even though I get a Big Thrill
out of the violence and the set pieces
and you can just thrill out of all the
darkness darling mommy doesn't go near
the darkness but between you and I was
just talking to Heather langenkamp and I
think about Neve Campbell all the time
there is always that that really strong
through line of fight a tinge of Hope
often in a lot of these movies and
that's what makes me feel empowered as a
fan and as a person in general as a big
horror lover so well you're not a horror
lover at all you know I'm a horror hater
I hate it I I don't want to be scared I
I don't enjoy it there's nothing about
it I enjoy nothing and yet it has given
me my entire life and so I have great
reverence for it appreciation for the
fans appreciation for people who lean
into it and dissect it and live it and
chew it and eat it and digest it and
love it and metabolize it into their
lives and I don't and so
um you know it's a it's a it's been a
complicated
dance for me and um
but without you I don't have a career
and so I'm grateful to you well I'm
grateful to you because I say this all
the time I use horror as a way to
process difficult human truths that I
can't come face to face in the real
world with but I can do it when I watch
it from a safe distance and I'm seeing
it in a movie and that happens in a lot
of my favorite franchises do you know
Michael Moses do you know who he is
Michael Moses is the marketing head of
marketing for Universal okay and I've
made three movies with him
and Michael Moses
wrote this line
as an introduction for me at cinemacon
and I remember reading this whole long
paragraph that I tried to make my own
words
and then there was this sentence in the
middle and I remember reading it and
going like ah
who wrote that
horror lets us confront what we can't
control
boom it's amazing and that's Michael
Moses
head of marketing movie loving-ness in a
nutshell right there all right I already
got the rap sign with you but I am gonna
I'll pivot to like a fun silly question
so you're you're very very
um attached to Lori clearly but there
are many iconic final girls out there so
if you had to swap roles with any other
one who would you choose and why
I've never seen anything how could I
ever see any of it I'm not that's very
I'm not lying
I uh Freaky Friday scared me I mean I
don't like any of it I know Nev so I'm
gonna say Nev because that I know her
well you know what I mean we're we're
acquaintances so I'm gonna say Nev
because I know she is
in a movie
but I don't I've never seen the movie
and I never will see the movie and I'm
going to show you why I've never seen
the movie oh no she it's my second
favorite movie of all time
there is one reason and one reason only
that I don't like horror movies
because since I was a baby I have been
terrified
since I was born I was born scared look
at that face
that is the face that I make all day
long okay I made it when I was whatever
age that was
I'm always looking over my shoulder I'm
always going like wait what what what
happened what what what is it I'm that
person so that tells you it's not acting
it is my natural uh a state of being if
I had my phone with me I would show you
a baby photo and it would be the exact
opposite of that face and that's how I
came into the world just like inject all
of this in my eyeballs because I love it
yeah wow oh yeah and that's why you're
now at collider you know what yeah
probably I think uh more so than
anything the iconic horror franchises
were my Gateway but I'm deeply
appreciative of every genre every form
of Storytelling you name it I just want
to I don't know experience other
people's truths experience things that I
can't in real life you name it and by
the way I owe you my entire career
people like you
have given me a career I wouldn't have
had a career I just wouldn't have found
a foothold Halloween gave me that end
and now you know that was made way
before you were born but now uh you've
continued to employ me and I appreciate
you very much um got awful at receiving
a compliment not giving one back but I
am here I have my career because of the
work you do so thank you right back to
you God bless you you're awesome